austria's government has approved a new
lockdown which will only apply to
unvaccinated people starting at midnight
on sunday the government said people who
haven't been vaccinated will only be
allowed to leave their homes for
essential reasons such as working
shopping or taking a walk the lockdown
is intended to push more people to get
the jab against covid19
now austria's decision comes just two
days after the netherlands announced a
partial lockdown for all residents
austria has one of the lowest
vaccination rates in western europe
together with chancellor alexander
schallenberg interior minister karl
nerhammer held a press conference a
short while ago here's what he had to
say
up morgan
as of tomorrow
every citizen every person living in
austria must be aware that they can be
checked by the police at any time
among other things we will also check if
people have been vaccinated or recovered
and the reason for entering public
spaces
i'm joined now by journalist klaus
prompters what do people in austria
think klaus do they think a lockdown for
unvaccinated people is reasonable action
for the government to take
protesters in front of the chancery in
austria and vienna already indicated
that not all people think this will be
helpful
they still protest against the measures
now taken
starting at midnight and experts already
said this is not enough
so the health minister already told in
his press conference
joined by the chancellor and the
interior minister we heard just now
we will discuss further measures in the
next days so that we really get a better
vaccination rate and already in the last
four days indications show that
four times more people have been
vaccinated than in the last two weeks
before
it applies especially to upper austria
and salzburg where the infections are
very high and as you all know germany
put
austria on the list of high infectious
uh
areas last friday
class what about how this works how will
the government actually control the
implementation of this uh unvaccinated
lockdown
police will go and control at random so
not everybody will be controlled
especially the fact is that the public
transport is accessible to everybody
bearing ffp2 masks but this at random
control indicates also if you are caught
and you are on the streets without one
of the purposes you just heard by the
interior minister
then you can be fined up to 1450 euros
a lot of people think this is in a
country like austria with a lot of
countryside
still not possible to control everybody
and so the spreading of
cobit 19 will go on and everybody
expects that in 10 days from now new
measures will be taken
class prompters in vienna thanks so much
for your time